hey what's up guys my name is andrew ray
i host a youtube series called binging
with babish where i recreate foods from
movies and television but today i'm here
at the laboratories at tasty i'm gonna
show you how to make three different
versions of pasta one that takes five
minutes one that takes 50 minutes one
that takes five hours each one is worth
making in their own rights i hope you
give them a try yourself let's get
started with pasta i love leo this is
the pasta i first learned about from the
movie chef we're gonna cook this just
shy of where we want it to be because we
want to finish cooking it in the sauce
we got some nice salted pasta water here
drop this in and as soon as the pasta
hits the water it's going to bend pretty
easily just try to coax it all down in
there while the pasta cooks we need to
work on the actual five-minute portion
of making this pasta which is making the
sauce we're bending the rules a little
bit you know this is really going to
take like seven minutes but just just
chill okay this pasta holds a very
significant place for me and the show
it's a very powerful dish for home cooks
because like i said it's encouraging
it's something that you can make very
easily that's stunningly good it
surprises you with how good it is one
thing with chopping herbs that makes it
a little easier is you can just sort of
press them all down into a little bunch
like this and run the knife through and
you want your parsley shop pretty fine
look at that you gotta love fresh herbs
we're starting in a cold pan half a cup
of olive oil just enough to coat the
bottom of the pan then into the cold pan
we have very thinly sliced garlic this
garlic is sliced so thinly it would burn
very very quickly we want this to just
barely turn blonde that's the color
we're looking for you don't want stark
pale white garlic all over your stark
pale white pasta especially if you're
stark pale white like me okay i'm seeing
a little bit of brown color around the
edges there that's exactly what i want
before i add the pasta we're going to
toast the red pepper flake just a little
bit we want that to have a little bit of
heat oh man that's going to be good in
goes the pasta
and a little bit of pasta water that's
going to halt the cooking of the garlic
and it's going to help us make a more
cohesive and lovely sauce and now is
also the time that we're going to add a
whole bunch of parsley go a little
overboard with the parsley why not live
your life the lemon juice i'm catching
most of the seeds this is a hard lemon
oh lordy lord yes now we need to of
course season with salt
see all that beautiful garlic parsley
and red pepper flake there we go this is
the carving fork from the movie chef
john favreau was kind enough to give it
to me people keep asking me when are you
going to bronze and frame this and i'm
like it belongs in my drawer it belongs
twirling pasta this is what it was made
to do this what it did in the movie i'm
not gonna deny it that because it's some
kind of trophy that's what he would
probably want me to do a great way to
serve up this pasta is to twirl it into
a nest using a soup ladle
so we got a nice nest here
i'm going to scoot it down a little bit
it's going to help it kind of stay
upright when we
end up in the plate here this is good
for a crowd here this isn't quite one
serving but that's okay
so this is a five minute pasta i lo olio
it's very very exciting to make
something so easily so quickly with so
few ingredients that taste so good use
the edge of the bowl when you're toiling
your pasta
this is the way you do
[Music]
oh it's just it's it's simple but it
surprises you with like
it's good
time to make the 50-minute pasta which i
think the best candidate for this is
fettuccine alfredo with homemade
fettuccine kind of put a mound of flour
on the table it's just got to feel like
a little
flower
volcano i don't know so i like to crack
my eggs on the table that's important a
safer way to make sure you don't get
none in there especially if we're doing
it
here
in
flour where it's going to be really hard
to dig out egg fragments and you can see
it's breaking nice and clean there's no
fragments no shell sometimes people like
to add a little bit olive oil to their
pasta a little drop and a little bit of
salt gotta salt your pasta using a fork
i'm just gonna start beating this
together and then just starting to take
in more and more flour it's getting nice
and thick i've rarely gotten it this
thick before without it spilling out i'm
just going to use a bench scraper like
this guy just sort of bring everybody
together here with pasta dough you want
it tacky but not sticky it took me a
while to figure out is that if you want
that really chewy al dente texture that
you're going to get from like restaurant
handmade pasta you really need to need
the ever loving shot of it my
relationship with fresh pasta like most
home cooks is a tumultuous one it's
something that takes a lot of practice
and intuition to figure out what you're
looking for what it's supposed to feel
like what it's supposed to look like
it's been a long and strange road and my
book is tempano from big night which
involves a whole lot of fresh handmade
pasta it's pretty bananas it's pretty
nuts you could knead it by hand or you
know why would you if you get one of
these
lock it down away we go
i'm gonna go ahead and
shut this guy down this is feeling
pretty good it's nice and supple and
tacky stretch it a little taut here poke
it and see if it springs back see how
it's not staying indented it's coming
back out like that that means that we've
got good gluten development i'm gonna go
ahead and wrap this in plastic wrap
we're gonna let it rest at room
temperature for 30.
nobody saw that right we're wrapping it
tightly and tightly in plastic wrap
letting that rest at room temperature
for 30 minutes
see you then
our pasta dough is well rested i'm going
to cut it into more manageable pieces to
start roll him into a ball and i just
want to give it a head start on the
shape that i'm trying to get it into
which is a rectangle roll it into a ball
and roll it out it's going to come out
like a big oval and you're going to have
a lot more waist flower this little bit
and before we actually roll this out
we're going to laminate it which is the
act of rolling it out folding it on
itself and re-rolling it not only is
going to help us get that you know nice
rectangular shape that we're after but
also is going to improve the pasta's
texture rolling it out again it's about
as thin as you can get it with the
rolling pin it's pretty good and we're
just going to feed it through it's just
the like
passing it through again and as long as
we don't see any like stretch marks or
tearing or anything like that we're
pretty much in good shape here passing
that through again make sure each side
of the dough is just lined up perfectly
with the rollers that way you don't end
up bunching there we go we got two nice
sheets of pasta here these feel
righteous take out the rolling
attachment and attach the cutting
attachment dust this with a little bit
of flour and straight on through the
cutters we got our first strands of
fettuccine for a fettuccine alfredo
twist it into a little nest the less you
fold the pasta the less you crease it
the more it's going to come out nice and
smooth and unfolded when you cook it
away we go
beautiful with alfredo the sauce
congeals and gets way too thick and
gloopy really really fast so you need to
work quickly you need all your stuff all
laid out and pre-measured ready to go
this is called nisan plus it's french
for everything in its place and this
method is developed by america's test
kitchen to try and make a slightly
thinner sauce than you might be used to
when you make fettuccine alfredo i have
a great personal story about fettuccine
alfredo i've never made it we have one
cup of heavy cream in here along two
tablespoons of high quality butter put
this over medium ish heat and we're
going to cook it down by one third
it's been about 15 minutes we've reduced
this by about a third you can see that
when i drag the spoon across the bottom
it's thicker than it was before and i've
been stirring this pretty constantly and
i'm going to add half a cup of heavy
cream this is going to halt the cooking
process now we got ourselves the nice
space for the sauce season this with
salt half a teaspoon's worth kosher and
maybe a half teaspoon of freshly ground
black pepper so i'm just stirring that
until the salt is pretty much dissolved
place it right over here and we're going
to start doing our pasta and salt the
water too and by keeping our bowl warm
like this it's going to keep the pasta
warmer longer it's going to keep the
sauce from congealing just a little bit
longer so we'll set that aside keep it
warm then directly into the water goose
our little nests of fresh pasta it's
pretty much done when it floats and i
also want to not fully cook it i want to
cook it just shy of where i want it to
eventually be then as soon as this is uh
almost done we're gonna add it straight
into this sauce and finish cooking it in
the sauce spider this stuff out and it's
okay if we're getting a little bit of
pasta water in there we want some to end
up in the sauce anywho we got an ounce
and a half of freshly grated parmesan
cheese and some freshly grated nutmeg
oh it smells so good
really makes all the difference in the
world cook this for one to two minutes
until the cheese is all melted we're
just gonna add a quarter cup of pasta
water and that is going to prevent the
sauce from getting too gloopy too
quickly oh smells so good my god i'm
just going to give this a little taste
that's good man those folks over at
america's test kitchen sure know what
they're doing and you see how it's not
kinky that's because we rolled it into
nests it's time to plate up all right
i'm gonna try to get all this pasta in
one go
and
into the bowl it goes oh look at that
daddy oh i'm just gonna grate a little
bit more fresh nutmeg over top so this
is a 50-minute fettuccine alfredo pasta
and sauce made entirely from scratch and
it is worth every minute i promise
oh my god it's really quite good
[Music]
thanks man double high five we did a 50
minute pasta onto the five hour joint
this is a slow cooked sunday gravy kind
of an italian-american staple it's just
a slow-cooked tomato sauce that becomes
deep and rich and complex have your
friends over serve them some meatballs
some veal shank they'll thank you for it
literally they'll be like thank you for
this sauce i just predicted your next
sunday
you're welcome first step is we need to
sear some meat in a big heavy cast iron
enameled dutch oven like this guy some
short rib bone in
and we have a couple uh pieces of beal
shank or veal asobuko the meat is going
to be
a lot of flavor but this is marrow in
the bone here that's going to leach out
into the sauce over time and it's going
to give it some pretty profound flavor
we got a sausage here too but we're
going to we're going to deal with this
guy later he's hanging out until these
guys are done we want to get good color
on this we want some good fond on the
bottom of the pot we're getting ready to
flip our assobuco
oh yeah
nice brown crust on there that is flavor
color that's good uh this guy got some
great color that's nice you might not be
able to see it but we got some nice
spawn in the bottom of this pan i'm just
putting in like a little less than a
tablespoon of olive oil and onions go
right in finely minced you see all the
brown flecks on there that's not
browning on the onions that is the fawn
from the bottom of the pot that's our
meat residue which sounds gross but it
is the foundation of most great flavors
in slow and low cooking and we're just
sweating these onions which means that
we're cooking them over
moderate heat until they become a little
translucent around the edges there we go
that's looking pretty good because we're
gonna add maybe seven cloves of garlic
peeled and crushed i'm gonna add a
little pinch of red pepper flake
teaspoons worth of dried oregano three
tablespoons of tomato paste just
sauteing this for like one minute just
until it starts to re-thicken this is
starting to smell a little less raw a
little bit more garlicky that's about
where we want it and now i'm going to
deglaze the pan with dry red wine like
pinot noir or cabernet sauvignon you
don't have to add red wine to your
tomato sauce it's a very
italian-american thing to do i don't
think they do that in italy at all i
might be wrong let's get the anchovy
paste in there get that good and mixed
in make sure it's all dissolved a few
finer ways to spend a sunday afternoon
than letting something bubble away slow
and low on your stove watch binging with
bavish
watch this video and learn a little bit
about food and if you're not careful a
little something about yourself
all right so now it's it's tomato time
this is four cans of peeled san marzano
tomatoes and these have been processed
lightly just to make it relatively
smooth about halfway full i'm going to
grab our pieces of veal shank and our
short ribs i'm just going to nestle them
in there and then i'm going to keep just
ladling sauce i'm going to put enough in
here just to cover everybody up there we
go and i'm also going to add cup and a
half of water i'm going to start there
and i'm going to add more as necessary
as the sauce cooks we're also going to
add a whole stem of basil also a lot of
people are tempted to add sugar to their
tomato sauce if you just let this cook
for four or five hours it's going to
become sweet but something that's gonna
speed along that process is a carrot
we're gonna fish those out before
serving and we're gonna fish out the
stem of basil and if the meat has fallen
apart we're gonna fish the bones out
partially cover this we want a little
bit of steam to be able to escape and
allow the sauce to mellow out and become
sweet and complex then in the last hour
of cooking we'll probably add two
sausages we're also going to be adding
water periodically throughout the four
hours that this guy's going to simmer to
make sure that we maintain the right
consistency we'll see after that
it's been five hours i haven't moved
from this spot and i'm ready to unveil
the slow cooked sundae gravy
i don't know why i just spoke french
this is italian we got some nice little
bubbles you can see that it is thickened
the harshness of the raw tomatoes have
mellowed out and have been replaced with
richness and sweetness now we're going
to fish out all of our non-edibles here
as you can see our asobuko's completely
fallen apart replaced by a hunk of
tomatoes carrots out there's the short
rib bone there's little hunks of meat
all throughout but there are still big
servable chunks that you're going to be
able to put on the side when you serve
this pasta the traditional way to plate
this is to toss the pasta with a little
bit of sauce and serve it with the meats
i'm going to take it one little step
further just to amp up the pasta a
little bit bam thin out the sauce just a
wee bit you could also thin this out
with fresh tomatoes from a can sometimes
a little brightness is welcome if the
sauce is super rich this is just about
the perfect consistency that i'm looking
for here and i'm going to
scoop this out of my way we want to
finish cooking the pasta in the sauce
also i want to talk about uh pasta
shapes and the kinds of pasta you want
to be looking for so we've got widely
available inexpensive pasta over here
and it's perfectly fine but you see how
smooth it is you see how like it's
almost shiny you want roughness when
it's cooked is going to create a surface
that is ideal for
absorbing and
clinging to sauce so to finish the pasta
we're going to add a healthy amount of
sauce to a pot with the cooked pasta
this pasta has been cooked to just shy
of al dente and of course we're adding a
quarter cup of pasta water we just got
this over medium heat we're just going
to finish cooking it in here the sauce
is pretty much like soaked up and
coating the pasta lovely so i'm going to
kill the heat now now i'm going to
finish the sauce with butter this is the
best way to finish red sauce it's a
world of difference it's putting a sheen
on the pasta and it's just making it so
much richer and it's gonna make it stand
on its own look at that it's gorgeous
and now we're gonna play it up look how
rich and orangy that sauce got my god
and i'm gonna try to crowd this to one
side as much as i can because we want to
make room for all of our lovely meats
sausage over here i'm just trying to
grab as many big hunks of meat as i can
garnish with a little bit of freshly
chopped basil and a little grating of
parmesan cheese and this is it this is
our five hour pasta sundae gravy all
that work it's about to finally pay off
let's start with pizza pasta
that just tastes like sundae when i was
a kid alvin come on over
um
wow oh you okay cheers
hey
okay
fourth battle
oh yeah yeah this meat's just falling
apart they're so good
six high fives watch out
that's a world record ladies and
gentlemen so the recipes for today's
dishes are available in a few places you
can find two of them the pasta is olio
and the five hour tomato sauce in my new
cookbook the binging with babish
companion cookbook it is out in stores
october 22nd and you can pre-order it at
bingingwithbabish.com
cookbook we learned that uh whether you
spend five minutes or five hours making
pasta if you employ a few techniques a
few tricks you can end up with something
gorgeous i hope you guys give it a try
for yourselves and uh
peace
[Music]
you